what up guys going back to cali today
just dropped off tiger at school and it
makes me happy that he gets less and
less sad every time i leave because the
first time i dropped him off i forgot if
i recorded it or not but man he was so
sad like he just saw my bags and goes
papa where are you going and i'm like oh
i'm going to california and he goes
he's like don't go don't go and i was
like papa has to go to work he goes
don't go
don't go to work and i was like oh
it hit me in the heart you know i'm like
oh my god this is what it feels like you
know when all those dads always talk
about leaving for work or even worse
when they get deployed and they're gone
for a long time and i'm like dude i'll
be back in like three days and he goes
three days and i'm like oh
but now this morning he was like papa
where are you going i'm going to
california and then he's like when are
you going to come back and well actually
you're going to go see grandma in a few
days he goes oh a few days i'm like yep
he goes oh so i won't see you for three
days but yeah probably like three days
and he was sad for a barely a little bit
like okay i'll see you on friday i'm
like oh that's cuny so on friday uh
right after school mama's gonna take
taika straight to california and i'm
excited
because uh if you guys saw
the last couple days vlogs we made a
seafood boil and by we i mean john and
malia and we had a bunch left over
so i'm bringing this over to jill's
brother he loves seafood
so i'm putting like all the shrimp
potatoes crab
some rice
a little ice pack so it keeps it nice
and fresh
because i'll be driving
and the cool thing is joe who's been
staying with me this entire weekend will
be driving with me as well and that's
super convenient
because i'm gonna be dropping off my
truck
so right now i'm in the garage trying to
find the other ice pack which i believe
i have yes
right there that's my leftover birthday
cake she probably should throw that out
it's like three months old that's
disgusting
but yeah i wanted to get
another ice pack just to make sure that
it stays nice and fresh especially
since it's seafood you know how like
seafood can go bad
real quick
so i got another ice pack and i think
just to keep it extra safe i might even
just duct tape the styrofoam
because there's gonna be a lot of
movement joe's going to come with me to
the truck shop which
i'll show you some of the stuff i'm
about to get done my truck's going to be
freaking sick and then i think at that
point i'm like 95 done with it which
means
the only other stuff that i'll do is
very very minor
and uh yeah so he's gonna drop me off
there then when i drop my truck off then
i have to ride with joe so i'm
trying to minimalize the packages that i
have
but i still have quite a bit i got this
which is the food
i have my luggage and i brought way more
this time because i'm going to be here
or be in la for a week and not only for
a week i'm also going to be shooting
some barbell content so
they need me to like bring some of the
other clothes to model because they're
dropping two more teeth by the way
if you guys haven't checked out the
launches we had this year we had a bunch
of sick launches we had this one breaker
i'm wearing it's from the ascend
collection good morning
good morning
okay i got this windbreaker from the sun
collection
uh we just dropped those flannel jackets
uh stretch denim made for people with
bigger hips bigger butt bigger legs so
go to barbergate.com and we're dropping
a few more casual base tees called the
legacy tees and uh
i'll be shooting for that this
weekend
all right guys i don't know if i showed
you guys the update on the truck yet but
two weeks ago i brought it into the shop
and i got my front bumper color match it
looks super nice i put the rings on
finally so it looks super clean
and it has that whole storm trooper look
and then on this side remember i had
that uh big dent because i hit the
telephone pole i got all that fixed and
then yesterday boom
joe hit my car
what happened dude
i was backing it up and it scraped it
scraped the grill on my car oh my god
i didn't even have my car for two weeks
i'm so sorry no it's uh i'm just not
used to how freaking big it is and um
it was dark and we weren't i don't know
i just uh
yeah
i wasn't i wasn't thinking
you're not true homies unless you crash
each other's car and uh
i also stole jill's sweater so i'm
wearing her sweater you wear a sweater
what the [ __ ]
i swear to god the last couple of years
leading up to this here has felt like
it's the end of the world like first of
all we had a giant pandemic right and
then you guys remember in austin texas
there was no apocalypse where like i
think was in the middle of summer where
pipes froze and
they couldn't get um the trucks to the
supermarkets or they're running out of
groceries their infrastructure couldn't
handle it
and then just this a few weeks ago we
had the super bowl and we had a heat
wave in the middle of february and it
was the hottest recorded super bowl ever
it was 90 something in la in february
and now i'm driving to la and look at
this
what the heck is going on
this is the craziest fog i've ever seen
it's insane and it's
47 degrees outside at 11 o'clock
damn it's raining hard i turned the
four-wheel drive on
just in case cause i already saw a
couple of accidents on the side of the
road
but
it is nuts
should probably get a little further
away from this car
raining hardcore
if it wasn't like noon which to me it's
crazy because noon usually means it's
really bright
um i bet it'd actually probably be
snowing it's probably going to be
snowing tonight here which is good news
if i were snowboarding but i'm shooting
just kidding news but maybe in a week or
two i might hit the slopes
[Music]
just got to ltw the shop that i go to
riverside right here and i'm definitely
going to check out that truck in a
little bit but just to update you guys
what i'm gonna get on my truck
um i'm gonna get some pillar lights so
those are the lights that go right here
one right here one right there i'm gonna
get the yellow ones so when i go through
either the fog like we just saw earlier
or if i'm running through the desert and
there's a lot of dust i'll be able to
see past that i'm gonna do a bumper chop
so they're gonna cut the bumper halfway
right here and then put a skid plate so
that we have a little bit more clearance
so when the clearance is or approach
angle so when you're like approaching
like big dips and stuff like this where
there's like a crazy angle this bumper
will actually scrape so
you don't want that obviously when
you're going off-roading so i'm gonna
cut that off and i'll give it like a
more tucked in look so look like the
tires are even bigger which is really
cool and then on my skid plate front
bumper i'm gonna put like a whole row of
lights there
and that's gonna look freaking sick and
when i'm driving like midnight back and
forth from uh l.a to vegas or vegas to
la you know when it's just pitch black
that way i'll be able to see the road
completely and nicely
and one thing you won't be able to see
that's not for show but hella function
you see that um thing right there that's
called a leaf spring
so the back suspension or the
articulation of the wheel is determined
by the shock which i have the fox shock
and how that rotated and then also the
leaf spring the leaf spring that i have
on our stock so they are a little bit
stiffer and the reason why they're stiff
is when you're loading the truck bed
like if you're putting heavy weight back
there
the stiffer it is the more it keeps uh
prevents the truck from sagging
so
uh i'm gonna put it into an off-road
leaf spring which will be a little bit
softer but if i do load the truck with
something heavy it'll sag more which is
fine that's rare that i put something
that's over 500 pounds back there just
usually just gear and stuff but i'm
gonna go check out that sick ass truck
now
oh man this thing is sick
those are some nice pillar lights
i wonder if i'm getting the exact same
ones but these are really cool it bolts
in it doesn't have to uh
go into the sheet metal this guy got
fiberglass fenders on the outside
to put these big old tires on i think
these are 37s and then mine are
i wish i could rock some 37s
but i do commute a lot as you guys know
so that would destroy my gas mileage so
i got to be a good boy and stick with
the 35s
oh we got the same setup in here though
he has the missoula upper control arms
the fox shocks i'm sure they have the
long travel system
but i can't tell it oh yeah they do
long travel you can see their lower
control arm right there
and that helps like the wheel like tuck
up and down and you can hit jumps and
stuff
this thing is dope
looks sick wow
it's beautiful
time for a little rest stop i love
restaurants like this joe found this
restaurant called uh
country kitchen country country folks
country folks and i love like old home
style restaurants like this
even though they're playing n-sync which
is really funny
but like look at the decor
it's old school feeling feels homey and
we came in because of the french toast
but then we asked him what should we get
he goes oh easy everyone gets the
chicken
no really oh what do you what do you get
do you get the chicken through your
french toast the chicken oh okay i'm
getting the french i mean the chicken
okay i'm gonna do i'm gonna get chicken
too see everyone thank you everyone keep
saying that even the server was like
people come from far to get it so i'm
glad we stumbled upon here i'm gonna
have to get you get it too i didn't have
to get like four pieces
[Music]
they must think i'm a child
putting this cherry on there and that's
because i am
every time i'm in one of these diner
places and i see their milkshake
i have to get one
okay
shakes are pretty thick it's really good
though
like a thicker thicker straw do but
thicker stick yeah nothing too skinny no
it doesn't have to be a long
chunk no just thick yeah these look good
yeah i like garbage
yeah that flows better
so they brought the chicken out first
no waffles but man this chicken looks
good
it looks crispy
oh man i want a wing
wow those look hooked up wow what
happened
this looks so good okay i got it i gotta
take a bite did you get a four piece
yeah
oh it's really hot but
but i can't wait
[Music]
and the battle is light boom
the waffle just came in
you gotta smear the butter nice and
evenly
that's like how that's how i like to do
things in these parts of town
like
that put it on like ice creams
and then add a little corner action
oh look it's melting that means it's hot
a little bit of this
a little bit of this action
dip it a little bit this action
and then
joe got it right too got some hot sauce
on the chicken
fries chicken baby
joe just dropped me off
at jio's mom's house
she's nice enough to let me borrow her
car which is super cool because
now that i'm in l.a i still have a
couple of errands i have to do like one
come to the jk office bam hello anybody
home
okay cool
and i'm gonna get some work done a
little bit and then i have to get a
haircut i was trying to get a haircut
this week
back at home usually i try to leave um
with a hair already cut
but since we're shooting on a slightly
different day this week
my barber in vegas closes
on sundays and mondays which is i think
pretty like normal because you feel like
everyone tries to get a haircut on
thursday and friday they look good for
the weekend you know so i think they
want to capitalize like on the weekends
and then so the slow day is probably
sunday monday so they're closed but it
just so happens that i need a haircut at
the beginning of the week which is
abnormal in my opinion
so i had to come out here and then i'm
uh go see my good buddy ben at vins in
alhambra so that's cool i get to go and
talk to old friends to get a haircut
and the reason why i like to get a
haircut usually before i leave somewhere
is anything could happen and then you
end up showing up there with messy hair
and not presentable you know so i try to
like get things squared away before i
leave so
if anything hits the fan like i'm still
ready to rock and roll
but yeah i got about an hour before it's
my
haircut time so i'm uh bang out some
work since i spent most of the day on
the road which which kind of makes me
lose out on half a workday i'm going to
bang that out and then go get my
hair cut
and it's awfully
quiet in here
when no one else is in here
here we are at the world's famous bins
in alhambra
hey what's up ben
how you been dude
i don't haven't
how many like three months i know yeah
we're talking about you all oh really
yeah where have you been you guys are
very patriotic today huh
yeah with the mask
america
all right let's do it and like always
ben always kills it on the haircut look
at that bam
oh i got a good
angle got a nice little fade going on
making me feel fresh
feel good for jk news
and then also i feel fresh for the
workout tomorrow so if you guys are ever
in alhambra or the east l.a area check
out ben at vince
i came all the way back from vegas just
to get a haircut now it's time
huh thank you thank you so much thank
you very much you've been cutting my
hair for how long um 10 years more than
that like 15. oh damn
you came you came when like you were
like
in high school yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
that's crazy yeah yes
that's crazy
all right just came back home
after i brought some food over to have
with uh jio's family
and what super cuny is
and ironic actually
is by us moving and particularly me
since i come back to l.a so often
i've actually been able to see
my dad and jill's family
way more because you know when we lived
in la
everyone was just 30 minutes away so
it's not too far not too close but then
you end up you know kind of just taking
each other for granted so we don't see
them as much they don't see us
and we're just kind of like just the
arms distance away you know but then now
that we're so much further by moving out
of state
whenever i come back in we make it a
point to
to hang out kick it and so now i see my
dad every two weeks
i see
jio's brother every two weeks we have
dinner every two weeks
and i actually have built a much better
bond with them by
living out of state which is super
ironic but now this cuny bed was made by
joe's mama i'm gonna get ready because
tomorrow gotta wake up early five six
go train and then go shoot jk news with
the boys so i'll see you guys tomorrow
good night